hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I just came
back from watching Fantastic Four 2015
and let me tell you it was one hell of a
movie I loved this film no no no it's
it's it's pretty bad bad movie Fantastic
Four more like anticlimactic for that
could have been better I read up on so
many reviews of this film I watched
plenty of critics on YouTube this is the
first woman a while where it feels like
everyone is in unison with their
feelings rather than trying to just
explain the plot to you here's what IMDB
has to say for young Outsiders teleport
to an alternate and dangerous universe
which alters their physical form in
shocking ways the four must learn to
harness their new abilities and work
together to save Earth from a former
friend turned enemy that is pretty much
the whole movie right there for starters
this film tries way too hard to try to
set up some world it starts off like
this is gonna be a character driven
science fiction piece then it ultimately
lands nowhere it goes nowhere
the film was just totally off like
everyone's saying this film takes itself
way too seriously like get a [ __ ]
sense of humor
a lot of people are comparing this to
Batman and Robin and a lot of people are
saying this is worse than that because
at least Batman and Robin was can't be
fun this film has no personality like
Jai Courtney no personality don't like
that actor just figured I'd take another
guy Courtney stabbed it's not fun at all
which is a real disappointment because
you have a great cast assembled miles
teller is Reed Richards Jamie Bell as
Ben Grimm Michael B Jordan as Johnny
Storm kate mara as Sue Storm
that's a [ __ ] awesome cast never will
complain I'm hearing and I totally agree
with it we could have gotten more from
kate mara and Michael B Jordans
relationship they established that kate
mara was adopted yet she's the one close
with daddy storm but Franklin storms
biological son the black member of the
new Fantastic Four Michael B Jordan but
he's straying away from family
this trying to be like Vin Diesel and
fast and furious instead so there's a
lot to explore there but no no no they
don't they don't even try then he got
Reed Richards who as a teenager let me
just start off by saying this film
starts off in 2007 but I swear they
portrayed it as if they were in 1953
then it cuts to seven years later and
Reed Richards must have like aged by
like 15 years enemy yeah Reed Richards
who is a teenager way too intellectual
for his age who may have finally found
where he belongs which might create some
conflict with him in Jamie Bell's
character Ben Grimm which starts off as
a strong dynamic relationship with Reed
Richards as his best friend yet Ben's
family life is not going so well but his
real family is Reed Richards and yeah
they they like lightly touch on that in
the most cliche expositional ways ever
they've actually introduced Victor Von
Doom who I guess is a rebel he already
has a jealousy towards Reed Richards
so yeah this film had me going maybe
it's just misunderstood because I like
where this is going at first like dr.
Franklin storm has the most generic
cliche speeches ever but I'm willing to
forgive that only because it's a part of
his character like the other characters
are always like you're he goes within
another speech so because of that
actually making them a part of the
character doesn't bother me as much but
a lot of it is very expositional and
very cheesy like this story starts off
as the first time these four come
together they're telling an origin story
so they start off by working on a major
science project which will land them
into some other dimension where they
take back something with them some type
of energy infection thing which gives
them the superpowers that we will come
to know as the Fantastic Four that would
have been a good movie that doesn't
happen to like close to an hour in this
film the first hour of this film is them
working on this science project and
there's like barely any obstacles they
gotta overcome everything goes smoothly
kind of according to plan all the time
all the way up until they complete it
but that's about like an hour of the
film with no action nothing really at
high stakes here it gets boring pretty
early on then when they get it together
mentioned it's cool I thought it was a
little intense then all of a sudden that
these time lapses in this film are so
horrible it really adds to the
disappointment of this movie like we
spend close to an hour waiting for them
to get their damn superpowers cuz that's
what the [ __ ] we came there to see I'm
all for character but come on throw in
some comic book flare it's not even good
character they finally get infected it
goes into a scene that felt like a
science fiction thriller then I was like
oh it's a buildup film this is where
it's about to get good I understand why
we waited that whole [ __ ] hour for
them to get the powers then know it
already cut the three weeks later five
minutes later it's cutting to a year
later they're telling us an origin tale
and they don't show you a lot of the
good things one of the best parts of an
origin tale is when they [ __ ] get
their powers and they start to use their
powers and they develop in advance and
all that yeah it's all canned it just
cuts to a year later war becomes a
completely different movie like
completely different it's like two
completely separate films we're in the
second film of it they tried jam packing
so much crap that it lost all sense of
character all sense of tone thrills and
and action there's like close to zero
action in this film and the thing
doesn't wear pants in this movie he
doesn't have a penis it's kind of
distracting and the visual effects and
CGI is not good I mean people can argue
about whether the
practical effect one and the one that
came out earlier would you know Chris
Evans and [ __ ] you know the one would
like Michael Chiklis is the thing one
could argue that this one looks better
but to me I was like me doesn't really
look that good a lot of the effects just
aren't that good I get it if it was like
some low-budget sci-fi flick but dude
this is from the studio that brought us
the x-men franchise we know you can do
better last act is where I hated this
film it becomes the definition of lazy
filmmaking like all around from the
actors to the writer director everything
you know I heard josh trank was an
[ __ ] about the whole thing I ain't
blaming you Josh Trank something kind of
tells me that it was a cross between an
indie filmmaker really wanting to make
his own artistic type of film with
Studio stepping in and kind of changing
things that's that's the vibe I get from
all that [ __ ] I've been reading about
but at the end of the day it's still a
shitty film like that finale from the
dialog to the forced themes and heroic
speech that just none of the gravity of
the situation is felt and what a stupid
[ __ ] it's a stupid ending you can
tell miles teller was doing a good job
but then the last half of this film
you're like holy [ __ ] he doesn't care to
do a good job anymore
and when we finally get doom holy crap
did they try rushing that in there all
the sudden and making it like a belt I'm
like dude what like dude just just
showed up and now we're in the fight it
trust me it's not a spoiler the whole
synopsis of everything you've been
reading is the entire movie and yeah the
mask on him was pretty [ __ ] terrible
couldn't even give him a mouth really
how is he supposed to suck on this was
like watching a bad 90s film not even a
fun bad 90 so I'm just a bad 90s film
you don't care about the characters the
film is uneven takes yourself way too
seriously literally has no personality
no thrills close to zero action and the
shitty thing is there's plenty of great
potential but laden mainly just missed
opportunities and the last act was
probably one of the worst comic book
movie finales I've ever seen I mean it's
pretty apparent how I feel about the
film by people can't
seem to understand the review unless
there's a rating system having an
established one so I'm just gonna make
up another one I would not eat out the
Fantastic Four's [ __ ] maybe you see you
storm but the other ones no anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter or vine and
periscope and really check out our
channel we got trailer reaction reviews
we got random YouTube video reaction
discussions we got movie reviews spoiler
reviews movie news vlogs unboxing videos
short films sketch we got a lot of [ __ ]
on here but were mainly just known for
reacting and no one cares about the
other stuff